[Music]
You're Gonna Leave
from dances
[Music]
to lip syncs
I'm awake
watch me
North this is not funny
goofing off and even celeb cameos
Kim Kardashian and Northwest are the
queens of tick tock she definitely has
Kanye's outgoing personality
and we'll say whatever is on her mind no
matter what it is now et's counting down
our 10 favorite mother-daughter Duo
moments from the clock app starting with
down here baby
[Music]
out Katy Perry to grooving to Taylor
Swift at number seven
there you go
[Music]
you just gotta roll with it and roll
with it she does remember when North
dressed up like Dad Kanye West
[Music]
and we can't forget about Kim and North
impersonating the ultimate momager Kris
Jenner
[Music]
[Applause]
up next an appearance from Mimi herself
Mariah Carey
[Music]
and of course Kim and North's famous fam
had to join in on the fun too
[Music]
everyone gets along everyone loves each
other
coming in at number two North delivering
such a Vibe by giving her mama major
side eye
[Music]
I don't know what's gonna top that
well we know because we think this
hilarious moment deserves the top spot
in our countdown of Kim and North's
silliest videos
um
yeah because Mia I'm awake
North this is not funny having kids is
just there's no way to describe it but
it's a lot a lot sure but thank you Kiki
and northie for blessing us with your
shenanigans
yeah I'm awake
North this is not funny
[Music]